go to the supermarket and there are
always offers to be had but many of
those products are high in fat sugar and
salt and come the autumn multi-deals on
such items were due to be banned
but now the government has backtracked
saying it wants to prevent a further
squeeze on living standards
that hasn't gone down well with health
campaigners like graham mcgregor a
professor in cardiovascular medicine
since 1980 we reckon they've been
approximately 30 plans from the uk to
try and prevent obesity
not one of them has been implemented and
what's happening is just getting more
and more obese
and it's a real disaster in public
health and it's really sad that boris
johnson has decided not to implement was
flagship policies he thinks the prime
minister has buckled under pressure from
some of his party's mps what he calls an
aggressive food industry and he's not
alone
boris wants to stay in power boris will
do anything to be in power he should
never have been in power
he never lied about who he was he lied
about what his policies were i don't
think they're helping people because if
health gets worse and it puts more
pressure on the nhs then it's going to
cost people more money in the long run
anyway i mean it is it's a good idea
isn't it because everyone's trying to
survive out here really hope it's been a
problem so yeah i mean to delay it it's
a good thing isn't it i'd say but
banning it i don't understand why
they've banned it in the first place in
theory the ban will be enforced 12
months later in october 2023 and an end
to junk food adverts on tv before 9 pm
will eventually happen in 2024 to
prevent children being targeted with
unhealthy treats
interestingly when you go into some of
the big supermarkets there's barely a
multi-buyer on offer it doesn't mean to
say there aren't deals though so this is
a shop of 10 items fruit veg meat fish
cakes biscuits cereal
it should have cost 22 pounds instead it
costs less than 16.
it could be a sign that stores were
already making changes to the way they
offer discounts knowing the bog off or
buy one get one free was soon to be a
distant memory
the government says the delay will
provide crucial time to understand the
impact the ban would have on shoppers
struggling with the cost of living
crisis but critics argue instead it's
playing politics with children's health
emma birchley sky news west london